there's only five ideas
uh i agree with that
i like podcasts that feature hosts with
no expertise delivering astonishing
advice to people about major life
decisions are big business i have
simulated a series of questions likely
to be submitted by listeners seeking
advice chad you must read these
questions to will
will you must dispense advice as arnold
schwarzenegger this is ask arnold begin
that sounds like fun so it's
it's advice stuff but doozy
doozy wrote these advice
questions i guess so
and uh it's arnold schwarzenegger
answering the so that's what this is
i think so dude here we go i
have eight questions in here for you
let's see what we can do are you ready
this is not in my thing it's only in
your
folder i have to ask them of you are you
ready
advice yes these are
simulated by dudesy yeah
yeah there he is look listen
there's so many podcasts out here that
everybody giving advice
and you know why who if you have
something in your life
that's big whether you who did talk to
a loved one a trusted companion now
talk to someone on the podcast
should go
arnold my grandmother is extremely
wealthy she owns a yacht and several
properties globally she's reaching the
end of her projected lifespan but i have
some siblings what can i do to make sure
she leaves me most of her material
wealth yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah now look
this is first of all you have to love
your grandma you know you have to love
her okay you don't just look for the
money you see what i mean but this this
person they want to have
do what they they they
they say that they end there
they want all of her material wealth
yeah this is a very
this is a very uh you know materialistic
person
so but i want to answer the question
because this is ask arnold and that's me
okay
so if you want to have all the material
wealth
you you you you have to get your stink
on it oh yeah you have to get your stink
on it how do you do that so if she has a
boat you know grandma has a boat
you know then what you want to do is you
want to go out in the boat with grandma
you want to create a memory
you know the grandma can't forget then
afterwards you be a very manipulative
person and you say grandma you know it
was so much fun when we went on the boat
after you're dead i'm gonna always think
of the boat but don't say when you die
right
just say you know
after you know she'll know what you're
talking about because she's old right
yeah so then you make a memory from this
okay and everything that you want to
have
all the these material things because
you don't love anybody because this
person the
pearson that the
piers and the
doozy made up here is not even a real
guy yeah he's an [ __ ] so you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] make
make try to he's trying to emotionally
manipulate all right that's my advice
that's pretty good advice here's our
next question arnold arnold i'm a
professional basketball player when i go
to the beach i get sand between my toes
how can i still enjoy the beach with my
team and not be embarrassed by my sandy
toes
yeah yeah yeah yeah this is a big
problem especially for basketball
players because they have big feet yeah
long toes yeah long toes big feet more
feet that you have
this more sand you can put in it
yes the more the more feet you have the
more sand you can have on the feet then
you you're playing they say the venice
beach
right by the muscle you know gold's gym
there are the mecca
on the beach you know muscle peach and
you know if i was there and i'm lifting
with franco colombo who also asked for
advice but then with franco colombo i
give him the wrong advices yeah you know
but here i give him the right advices
if you're over there then you you're on
the beach you're splashing around you
want to go uh boogie boarding a body
surf you know
then afterwards you before you want to
go to abbott kinney and have something
to eat at the tasting kitchen or maybe
uh you know uh
a bit kidney pizza i don't know if it's
there anymore gillina
you know
back in your heyday yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah back in the heyday have the uh you
know uh go over there have a check
i
have a
[ __ ] kudari board yeah [ __ ] kudri then
before you do this you have to pour
water on your toes before you go play
basketball on the court straight by
there then you go have something to eat
and that's the advices all right water
on the toes pretty good advice bring a
big bottle of water to where drink on
the show here's here's another one
dudesy has given us arnold
my husband loves pickled eggs we eat
them every night i've pretended to enjoy
them for 17 years because i know they're
his favorite but the truth is i'm
fatally allergic to pickles and eggs
i've built up my tolerance but lately
he's been demanding we eat more how do i
tell him i don't want to eat pickled
eggs anymore and still keep my marriage
yeah yeah yeah this is it this is a this
advice is is for a domestic problem you
know yeah yeah
now a lot of people in marriages have
different issues that they need to
you know
uh get through
yeah you were married for a long time
yeah yeah yeah i was
um and the thing about that is sometimes
it's that you made a kid with somebody
else sometimes it's that you don't want
to eat the pickled eggs right yeah
so this is the way to not have a pickled
eggs you could say because i know
there's a nice
store up here in there um
what do they call it uh up in the
mountains here have been there okay
in the mountain store yeah yeah yeah all
right well anytime you go to the
mountains like big bear yeah or you go
up to uh i forget the name of it but
they have that jerky storage a lot of
places they sell pickled eggs
if you're deathly afraid to the eggs you
can have other things that are pickled
you know they have well this person says
also allergic to pickles
yeah yeah yeah fatally allergic to
pickles and eggs yeah then you need to
get a divorce
okay that's my advices for them all
right here's another one arnold my son
found out that i'm subscribed to too
many streaming services and he's forcing
me to reduce down to one which streaming
service is the best yeah i would
recommend doozy plus but do the plus is
not even there yet
only doozy knows what do the plus would
be
so i would say
to get uh
any the streaming service who wants to
do it
it's uh a person's son found out that
he's subscribed to too many streaming
services and his son is making him cut
down to one yeah why the son want to do
this
see this sounds like the same thing with
the grandma
i'm just reading what dudes he wrote
yeah yeah yeah but he's a manipulative
manipulative guy here
[ __ ] that next one i don't like it all
right
arnold i think a co-worker wait hold on
all right the peacock
okay yeah the peacock
all right yeah yeah yeah peacock do you
know why they peacock
you want to know why yeah yeah peacock
yeah why because peacock has all the wwe
network oh yeah
okay
arnold i think a co-worker has a crush
on me but our corporation has a strict
no dating policy what is the best way to
file a report that gets my coworker
fired so i can advance you have to say
you have to say that the the person
had the sex with you
that way they get fired
and then you can date them and this is
the best way to keep it the real thing
if you actually have sex
and like alex jones says you leave a
little the semen a little bit of the
breast milk
maybe even a little blood
they could test this and they go yeah
this semen this blood this breast milk
belonged to this guy
you know how they make breast milk i
don't know but you have to fire him
[Music]
maybe yeah then then that way yeah that
it
you can date this guy also you have now
had sex with him
or is it the girl
who said it it just says i think a
coworker has a crush on me but our
corporation has a strict no dating
policy well it's the best way to file a
report you can't be anybody it could be
anybody it could be two guys two ladies
they the point is they want to have sex
with each other the best way to have sex
is to [ __ ] that person
first that way you know i like it i like
having sex with you
yeah and then you file the report then
you file the report and one of you has
to be the dna evidence yeah the the
breast milk this semen okay
now then you have to decide who's gonna
go yeah who's gonna stay but it's okay
because you like to have sex so much
that you might be married and one of you
stays home and is the home taker yeah
the home the homemaker
and then the other one says i worked all
day i just want to come home i have a
pickled eggs [ __ ] you no
i can't either allergic yeah my tongue
gets all blown up and then i can't
perform a cunnilingus
because my tongue is all my my taste
buds are all spiky and then yeah that's
why i like them i like your taste buds
and your big tongue all spiky that's why
i gave you the pickled eggs oh and the
first thing
yeah you [ __ ] you [ __ ] well he did
that that's good advices all right
here's another one arnold my father is
bono how do i tell him that i hate his
music
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah this is now
we're getting into doozy here because
then doozy will i
am will
yeah but i'm talking is
another person and that's how doozy you
do it yeah but i like you too
and i'm will and i went to a concert and
i cried i mean the bottle is singing in
so beautiful mysterious ways and cried
yeah and then the son has to say the
child here
the parent likes you too how do i tell
him that it's a terrible it's very
simple just play what no this this is
the
child is saying my father is bono oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah how would you tell
the lead singer of you too that you hate
his music especially if he's your father
i think is the advice yeah yeah yeah
it's very simple just play the album
youtube uh
zuropa
for bono yeah and then he'll go
i like this when i did it it's not very
good you're right okay that's good
yeah
because we listened to it it's been yeah
almost 30 years i haven't listened to it
i will we got one more here
arnold i've been a nintendo guy all my
life my soul mate only plays xbox how do
i convince my soul mate to switch to
nintendo
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
did the the soul mates here sometimes
you you have a soul mate and you there
you don't see either eye on everything
yeah you know whether it's pickled eggs
or if you both have a tit milk
the way to get someone to play nintendo
is to go hey
xbox
whether you want to do xbox
you could do red dead redemption you
could do
grand theft auto but he can't do his
mario kart
and this is the best game for a couple
because you can play all day
you can both instead it's very unhealthy
for a couple in the relationship or one
played video game they're they're
playing metal gear solid
usually the lady has to sit there and
watch it yeah and it's like yeah you
want to order some food you know let's
sit around like a couple of pieces of
[ __ ] and just you know order thai food
and just start farting and
shooting little squirts
the best is better to do
mario kart yeah because you start and
end the game
there's a start and the finish yeah
that redemption you could keep going
same as uh grand theft auto yeah those
are both rock star games yeah
yeah they're both rockstars
[Laughter]
no
because you do it's the same thing i
said before
before
listen if you do infomania you have to
do
the hulk hogan voice
do this yeah so
super mario kart because that way you
both play the same time then you stop
the game then you order the thai food
then you go make a poo because it's so
runny and maybe you don't you're
allergic to some sort of pickled egg
yeah that was in the food but it's okay
piggy [ __ ] maybe have a nap you know
drink some electrolytes because of all
the all the bile the water you poo from
your butt then go back and play mario
kart again
this is good advices that's why you play
mario kart
well it's pretty good i you know i hope
that all these non-existent people uh
heed this advice yeah yeah these are
some strange questions that doozy was
trying to simulate what i guess it
thought actual people were gonna say
yeah yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
thank you moving on
here
please tell a friend
if you like to see here's what you do
please tell a friend then break a
preview
if you
please like then